Also, außer die üblichen Verdächtigen, die immer am Start sind, wie auch immer die
das machen.
Und gibt es irgendwas spannendes, was heute passiert ist?
War irgendwas belegt gerade?
Der eine Typ aus John Wick ist gestorben, habe ich gelesen.
Also, Real Life, nicht in Movie, sonst irgendwas passiert noch?
Hoffentlich nicht, ich glaube nicht, nö, nichts spannendes, außer dass wahrscheinlich
wieder 5 neue JavaScript-Frameworks erfunden wurden heute und neue AI-Frameworks sind heute
entstanden.
Gibt es jetzt eine GTA-Version, die einen Runner hat?
Ja Moment, da war doch irgendwas, die wurden doch, warte mal, wie war das denn, da gab
es doch so ein Miniskandal gab es da doch letztens.
Irgendeine Firma aus Hongkong, wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe, irgendeine
Firma aus Hongkong hat doch da jetzt irgendwie so was übernommen und ich krieg's nicht mal
genau zusammen, was da gewesen ist, aber irgendwas haben die China-Chinesen jetzt mit GTA zu tun.
Codeberg hat's gefolgt, ja, die waren leider so blöd und haben ihm Dinge Namen gegeben,
was keines auch versteht und aussprechen kann, ich hab schon wieder vergessen wie das
Ding heißt.
Ja, also es ist irgendeine Firma aus Hongkong, glaub ich, ne China-Chinesen-Firma, die jetzt
bei GTA mit rein hängt und wie gesagt, ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen, die wollen
jetzt genau kommerziell irgendwas machen, aber mal gucken, ob da überhaupt irgendwas
nennenswertes passiert.
Guck mal mal, gibt's da jetzt, ach, hier kommt mal 19, wer ist hier 19, haben die Change-Logs?
SilverCross, danke schön für den Sub.
Okay, lass mal kurz hier, breaking, breaking, breaking, ja, ja, schön, wo ist das mit dem
Runner?
Run, Action, das heißt wahrscheinlich einfach Action, Implement Actions, naja, eigentlich
ist es ne ganz coole Geschichte, weil GitLab ist so krass bloated mittlerweile und braucht
irgendwie 85.000 Terabyte Speicherplatz und RAM, dass es überhaupt ordentlich läuft.
Oh, das ist wieder so Memes, die nur lustig sind für die Amis, weil wir den Kram ja auf
Deutsch verstehen.
Das ist so ein Ding, ich glaube in Deutschland kannst du so über der Untergang Memes nicht
lachen, weil du halt das Original verstehst, das ist genauso wie die Spanier wahrscheinlich
nicht über die ganzen El Resitas Abwandlungen lachen können, weil die den Typ verstehen.
Mein Gott, warum machen die eigentlich alle so hässliche Seiten, so nicht Dark Mode Seiten,
warum macht man sowas?
Ich hab übrigens mal jemand von euch Revolute ausprobiert, das ist eine, das ist eine App,
ein Webservice, ich muss, ich muss mal, mich immer mal ein bisschen dran erinnern, dass
ich eigentlich IT Mensch bin und die Sachen auch ordentlich nennen kann, ich mein man
sagt immer so schnell, das ist eine App, das ist aber eigentlich verkehrt, das ist letztendlich
ein Webservice mit unter anderem einer App und da kann man sich Visa und Mastercard One
Time Use Karten beziehungsweise zusätzliche Kreditkarten generieren lassen, was sehr
nice ist, weil vielleicht willst du ja nicht, dass jeder da hergelaufene Service deine Main
Kreditkarte kann, ja das ist wirklich cool hier, ich weiß es halt nicht, die hatten
letztens einen Data Preach, das meine ich, die hatten letztens irgendeinen Leak, ist
auch gar nicht so lange her, ein halbes Jahr ungefähr, das heißt wirklich trauen sollte
man denen nicht, aber Kreditkarten generieren ist halt praktisch, du kannst Single Use Kreditkarten
generieren oder neue Multiple Use, das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal verwendet für
irgendwelche Trial Accounts, ich habe mir nämlich einen Trial Account gemacht, ich
habe mir einen Google Cloud Trial Account gemacht, auch mit neuer E-Mail Adresse und
One Time Kreditkarte, das ging erst nicht, Google hat gesagt, das läuft irgendwie nicht
durch, aber dann konnte man auf doch freischalten und an den Supportwenden irgendwie schreiben,
und das war nur ein Button und jetzt irgendwie einen Tag später hat Google sich dann gemeldet,
hat gesagt, nö nö alles okay, hier haben sie ihre 300 Dollar Google Cloud Trial Zeug,
das ist ja nicht die erste Google Cloud Trial, die ich habe, aber ich mache ganz gerne immer
neue Google Cloud Trials, weil ich lasse ja da nichts Produktives laufen, ich übe und bastle
ja wirklich nur rum und ich habe keinen Bock 650 Euro für einen Google Kubernetes
Knast im Monat zu bezahlen, das muss ja nicht sein, also zeig mal, was hat dann, wie spricht
man das eigentlich aus Leute, Git-EA, One Time Kreditkarten gibt es auch, ja das ist ja alles
schön und gut, aber ich fahre nicht an die Tankstelle, du sagst Git-T, wahrscheinlich
die sinnvollste Aussprache, Poggers, Git-EA, das ist vielleicht auch nicht so toll, Shit-T-EA,
wird hier immer besser Chat, okay, lass uns mal gucken, was Shit-EA für neue Sachen hat,
ich finde es tatsächlich ganz nice, dass sie jetzt einen Runner haben, weil entweder benutzt
man GitHub und ist glücklich, aber man ist halt komplett in der Cloud, also wenn man das haben will,
oder wenn man da nix dagegen hat, kein Problem, also ich benutze eigentlich für nahezu alles
GitHub und sei es nur private Repos, ich habe allerdings auch ein lokales Git-EA noch bei mir,
für irgendwelche Quick and Dirty Sachen mal schnell pushen und so, wo ich nie die Absicht
habe, dass es irgendjemand sehen soll außer mir, stimmt genau, und Autopilot und Jet-GPT gegen
deine Software trainiert wird, ja gut, ist halt so, weiß gar nicht, haben die irgendwas dazu gesagt,
ob die bei GitHub auch private Repos zum Trainieren ihrer AI-Geschichten benutzen,
wisst ihr da was? Also ich meine im Zweifelsfall machen die das, ja keine Frage, ich glaube nicht,
dass sie da irgendwie sich zurückhalten, aber sie werden es wahrscheinlich keinem erzählen,
naja gut, also lasst uns mal angucken, wie gesagt, ich finde es ganz nice, ja für Jet-GPT und Co-Pilot
und alles mögliche, nein hatte ich nicht, aber meine Stonks, ich guck mal kurz rein,
Scalable, hallo, Scalable, meine Stonks sind, na ich glaube sie sind sogar wieder 100 Euro
hochgegangen, ja ein bisschen, aber immer noch minus 1.717 Stonks Euro, null,
okay, dann gucken wir uns, RWX-Cock, toller Name, kann ich gleich was zu sagen,
so, aber wir gucken uns mal kurz die Release-Notes an, naja und da kann ich auch die Frage beantworten,
für meinen Runner verwendet, also um das jetzt nochmal, steht für Clash of Clans, achso,
also spricht man es nicht cock aus, naja man weiß ja nicht, wir hatten mal bei uns auf der
Arbeit irgendein Projekt, das hieß auch CoC und ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ich glaube,
das stand da für Code of Conduct oder sowas wie Verhaltensregeln oder sowas, ja, so da hatten wir
mal ein Projekt bei uns auf der Arbeit und die Projektmanagerin, die hat immer gesagt, irgendwie
und wie steht es um Projekt CoC und alle haben sich immer gesagt, sprecht es halt nicht so
offensichtlich aus, was macht Projekt CoC, so also was macht Projekt Shitia, ich finde es ja gut,
wie gesagt, um das jetzt nochmal kurz auszuführen, wenn man kein Problem damit hat, alles in die
Cloud zu packen, auch sein Sourcecode, ist man bei GitHub eigentlich rundum zufrieden, finde ich,
GitHub hat ein paar Vorteile, die so, finde ich, die andere nicht haben, das erste offensichtlich ist,
du musst dich überhaupt nicht drum kümmern, also GitHub ist halt einfach da und GitHub ist
bis auf wenige Ausnahmefälle eigentlich auch immer ab, also gibt eigentlich, gibt eigentlich
ganz selten, was das GitHub mal dauernd ist, aber kommt ab und zu vor, also das ist wirklich
der erste Vorteil, das Ding ist halt einfach da, du musst dich nicht drum kümmern,
der zweite Vorteil ist bei GitHub, es ist einfach, ich meine, es hat schon mittlerweile ein paar Tiefen,
wo man in Menüs rumklicken kann, ganz im Ernst, GitHub Actions ist easy, das Freikontingent bei
GitHub ist auch nicht verkehrt, ich bin auch nie an das Limit vom Freikontingent gestoßen bei
GitHub, jeder auf der Welt verwendet GitHub, was natürlich auch zum Austauschen und share
nicht schlecht ist und GitHub ist einfach easy zu benutzen, wie gesagt, gerade GitHub Actions,
GitHub Actions ist eine super Geschichte und du hast eine Container Registry, finde ich,
GitHub ist, wenn man kein Problem damit hat, dass es in der Cloud ist, ist die beste Kombination
aus einfach und alle Features, die man braucht, du hast eine Container Registry, du hast GitHub
Actions und du hast deine Source Code Reboot, du kannst natürlich noch weitere Sachen machen,
es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit große Files abzulegen und solche Dinge, gibt ja richtig viele
Feinheiten, Codespaces, um im Browser zu entwickeln und so, ist schon cool, was die eigentlich im
Prinzip alles kostenlos bieten, aber wenn man kein Problem hat, dass es in der Cloud ist,
ist GitHub für mich die beste Variante, das andere Gegenstück dazu ist GitLab, GitLab kann man auch
in der Cloud verwenden, natürlich, keine Frage, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe nicht genau,
warum die Leute damals als Microsoft das übernommen hat, reinweise abgesprungen sind
von GitHub und zu GitLab, das war ja glaube ich der größte Useransturm, den GitLab je erlebt hat,
es gab noch Bitbucket zwischendurch von Atlassian, ich meine, das gibt es auch immer noch zum
Selbthosten, ja, aber Bitbucket ist bisschen auf dem absteigenden Ast, habe ich den Eindruck,
ist Bitbucket eigentlich Open Source, Neger? Das kenne ich nicht, das kenne ich nicht,
das sieht sehr China-Chinesen mäßig aus, was zum Teufel soll das sein? DevOps, Enterprise Edition,
alles klar, China-Chinesen Zeug, ist das das China GitHub? Komm, wir lassen es mal übersetzen,
ich gehe davon aus, dass es die Seite nicht auf, okay, alles klar, Code Eats the World,
Tools Change Efficiency, das China-Chinesen-Ding geht ja richtig ab,
alles klar, China-Chinesen Zeug, das ist das China GitHub und wenn man sich da registrieren will,
dann geht das wahrscheinlich auch nur auf Chinesisch, oder? Moment, Continue with GitHub?
So, also, wir gucken uns jetzt mal die Release Notes dafür an, ja, das Gegenstück zu GitHub
ist ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen GitLab, wo die Leute halt reinweise hin geflitzt sind und
weiß ich weiß bis heute nicht, warum die Leute alle so zu GitLab sind, die übelst schiss als
Microsoft den Kram übernommen hat, gut, ich meine vielleicht auch ein bisschen zurecht,
wenn man sich überlegt, dass quasi der gesamte Source Code durch CodePilot und alles durchgelaufen
ist, okay, aber so im Nachhinein ist die große Apokalypse bei GitLab ja ausgeblieben, so, also
das heißt für mich, wenn ich was in der Cloud verwende, dann verwende ich GitHub und fertig aus,
wenn ich was selbst hosten will, da kommt jetzt halt Shit her ins Spiel, da muss man halt sagen,
ist GitLab viel zu fett mittlerweile, es ist recht easy zum Laufen zu bekommen mit default
Settings, es gibt einen Helm-Chart für Kubernetes zum Beispiel, kannst es reinklatschen, aber da
hast du Probleme, dass der Runner nicht richtig funktioniert und so was, ein bisschen umdenken,
aber man muss sagen, GitLab selbst hosten ist riesen riesen bloated Mist, deswegen habe ich
lokal auch ein GTA laufen und nachdem die jetzt auch einen Runner haben und ich weiß nicht,
ob die eine Container Registry mittlerweile haben, anscheinend, Chat sagt, die haben eine,
dann ist das wirklich eine gute Alternative und ich würde sagen,
das müssen wir dann unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Ja, um jetzt mal, um jetzt das mal zu erklären, was man mit einem Runner macht, naja, damit
runnt man was, damit führt man was aus, gut, ich glaube, damit kannst du nichts anfangen,
ich zeig dir mal ein Beispiel, was man mit einem Runner macht, ein Runner ist ja eigentlich nur
ein Wort, was überall verwendet werden kann, wo was ausgeführt wird, man muss das im Kontext sehen,
und zwar im Kontext von Softwareentwicklung und in dem Fall geht es darum, dass wenn man zum
Beispiel neuen Source Code in sein Repo pusht, ich zeige euch gleich ein Beispiel, wenn man neuen
Source Code in sein Repo pusht und dann möchte man ja vielleicht, dass automatisch ein paar
Dinger passieren und diese Dinger, um es jetzt mal ganz abstrakt zu sagen, und diese Dinger
müssen irgendwo ausgeführt werden, die werden in einem Runner ausgeführt, also zum Beispiel,
schauen wir uns mal was an, was ich auf GitHub habe, aber kommt ja aufs gleiche raus, ich habe
die 5-fette Organisation, das ist übrigens ein Logo, so, guck mal, ich habe hier so eine kleine
Beispiel-App gebaut, die nichts macht außer Hello World auszugeben oder Q-Chat auszugeben oder so
was, ist auch egal, zumindest, ich will, dass immer wenn hier ein neuer Versions-Tag gepusht wird,
ihr seht, ich habe hier schon ein paar Tags gepusht, immer wenn ein neuer Versions-Tag gepusht wird,
dann will ich, dass ein neues Package gebaut wird und in die Container-Registry gepusht wird unter
hier diesem Namen, sodass ich dann Docker Pull machen kann oder Kubernetes Image Update oder
was auch immer und dann wird quasi das Container Image von meiner App automatisch erzeugt und kann
verwendet werden und das sieht dann so aus, GitHub Workflows, Docker Image bauen, das ist die
Definition, was der Runner ausführen soll und zwar, das ist jetzt GitHub Actions, das hat jetzt mit
GTA nichts zu tun, aber ich vermute, dass es in GTA relativ ähnlich aussieht und in GitLab sieht
es auch relativ ähnlich aus, das ist alles Jammel-Engineer-Time. So und da kannst du dann
zum Beispiel sagen, guck mal da, jedes Mal wenn ein neuer Tag gepusht wird, da habe ich Tags gepusht,
jedes Mal wenn ein neuer Tag gepusht wird, dann führe das hier aus, Leute, das ist noch ein
übersichtlicher Job, das geht noch viel komplizierter und länger. Man könnte damit zum
Beispiel auch Sonntagschecks machen, Tests laufen lassen und solche Geschichten, das ist jetzt
wirklich nur die allersimpelste Variante. So und wenn ein neuer Tag gepusht wird, also quasi jeder Tag,
der mit V anfängt und dann irgendwas hinten dran kommt, also zum Beispiel V0010 oder sowas,
ich muss sagen, ja, dann führt er das aus und zwar definiert man, wo er das ausführen soll.
Auf GitHub gibt es drei verschiedene VMs, die sind übrigens alle kostenlos, bis zu,
fragt mich nicht, 500 Stunden im Monat oder so oder 500 Minuten oder ist das auf jeden
Fall relativ viel. Also es gibt Ubuntu, es gibt Windows und es gibt glaube ich Mac,
wo man das drauf laufen lassen kann. Also es sind echte VMs, die man hier bekommt,
die wird im Hintergrund gestartet und dann werden folgende Jobs auf dieser VM ausgeführt.
Als erstes wird das ganze Repo ausgecheckt bzw. der Repo Inhalt wird auf die VM kopiert,
dann wird sich angemeldet in der GitHub Container Registry, als Secret wird hier das aktuelle
GitHub-Token verwendet, was automatisch in so einer Action bereitgestellt wird,
dann wird das Image gebaut und dann wird das Image in die Container Registry gepusht und das heißt,
bei jedem Tag, also jedes Mal, wenn ich einen neuen Tag pushe, dann wird quasi eine neue
Version gebaut von dieser App, die ich dann benutzen kann. So und das muss in einem Runner laufen und
das haben die jetzt anscheinend auch. Also das ist ein neues Feature bei Shithea,
dass die jetzt anscheinend auch sowas implementiert haben. GitLab hat sowas schon lange,
GitLab hat GitLab CI, sieht relativ ähnlich aus zu dem, was GitHub Actions macht. Warum ist kein
Dark Mode default? Ist immer ganz schrecklich. Hier, Docker. Gucken wir uns das Beispiel an,
ihr seht, das sieht relativ wenig aus für GitLab, Image, Docker, Latest, blablabla. Ich persönlich
muss sagen, ich finde GitHub Actions das Simpelste von diesen CI-Yammel-Definitionen.
Gibt sicherlich noch bessere oder noch einfachere, aber ich meine,
ich habe jetzt auch nicht jedes Continuous Integration System ausprobiert.
Und die machen ja, guck, du siehst hier, die machen im Prinzip genau das Gleiche,
nur ein bisschen anders. Ja und anscheinend haben die bei GTA jetzt auch sowas. Das Coole an GTA ist,
dass es relativ leichtgewichtig ist. Im Blog, in diesem Post sind Screenshots. Gucken wir uns
gleich an. Ich will nur mal schauen, was die sonst noch in der neuen Version haben. Also,
das ist relativ leichtgewichtig. Wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch liege, dann ist GTA selber
ein Fork und zwar von Gox. Was auch so ein Gitweb-Interface ist. Das ist aber schon
ein paar Jahre her, wo die davon geforkt haben. Haben sie eine Sekunde, um über Jenkins zu
sprechen? Ja, was soll ich über Jenkins sagen? Ich persönlich finde Jenkins eigentlich ganz nice.
Das liegt aber auch daran, Jenkins war so das erste wirklich bekannte, bei Jenkins ja auch nicht.
Hudson war ja noch der Vorgänger von Jenkins. Ich zeige euch das mal. Wer das noch nicht gesehen
hat, ist mit diesem komischen Dude da. Butler oder was das sein soll. Ich mag Jenkins,
es liegt aber hauptsächlich daran, weil damals, als das neu war, war Jenkins ja so das Einzige,
was es gab und ich habe damals relativ viel mit Jenkins gebaut. Mittlerweile, wir haben sogar
intern immer noch einen Jenkins von damals stehen. Der macht aber nicht mal wirklich viel.
Aber ich finde Jenkins insofern ganz nice, weil du mit Jenkins einfach alles machen kannst.
Das musst du aber halt von Hand machen. Du kannst in Jenkins jeden nur erdenklichen Job erstellen
zur Automatisierung. Das muss nicht zwangsläufig irgendwas mit Source Code direkt zu tun haben.
Also du könntest in Jenkins auch einen Job erstellen,
der deine Kaffeemaschine anschaltet, wenn die eine API hat.
Also insofern ist Jenkins schon ganz nice. Es ist halt ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen.
Es gibt jetzt ja Jenkins X oder irgendwie sowas. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das mit Jenkins noch
zu tun hat. Was auch immer. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich persönlich bin mit GitHub Actions
echt zufrieden. Meistens braucht man ja auch nicht Berge an Automatisierung bei einem Push.
Willst du eine Image bauen oder willst du vielleicht ein paar Tests laufen lassen?
Ja, es hält sich ja meistens in Grenzen. Deswegen finde ich GitHub Actions das Beste aktuell.
Ich gehe gleich durch den Chat durch, Leute. Ich bin noch ein bisschen hinten dran.
Okay, so und die haben jetzt auch einen Runner. Mal gucken, wie das Ganze aussieht.
Also sprich, das ist eine leichtgewichtige Alternative zu GitHub.
Hat auch relativ viele Sterne und ist glaube ich, glaube ich, glaube ich,
das ist alles in Go. Wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege, ja.
Das heißt, es ist zwar nicht Placingly fast written in Rust,
aber es ist auch in einem der coolen Programmiersprachen programmiert und es
ist relativ easy. Also du kannst hier, passt mal auf, man kann das, glaube ich,
sogar runterladen als Single File und starten. Alter, die hören ja gar nicht mal auf hier.
Ja gut, guck, ich kann das als Single File runterladen. Wo ist der Linux?
Als Single File runterladen und starten und es funktioniert. Ich meine, seriously, 113 MB,
da lacht sich, wir spielen heute gar nicht mit Kubernetes rum. Heute schwätzen wir einfach nur
ein bisschen. Da muss ich mal überlegen, GitLab, wenn du GitLab selbst hosten willst,
du brauchst acht verschiedene Container oder so oder noch mehr mittlerweile. Das hört überhaupt
nicht mehr auf. Ja, stimmt, das kannst du mit GitLab Actions auch machen, aber Jenkins ist in
so einem Fall halt cool. Du willst wahrscheinlich nicht, dass deine Kaffeemaschine ab hier aus dem
Internet erreichbar ist und halt so ein Webinterface mit einem Button Kaffee machen,
da so einfach wie mit Jenkins kriegst du das mit GitLab Actions nicht hin. Aber für alles andere,
was irgendwas mit Source Code und Packages bauen, Test ausführen, sowas zu tun hat,
finde ich, ist GitLab Action komplett ausreichend und so einfach zu bedienen,
dass es einfach das Beste ist aktuell. So, jetzt gucken wir das mal kurz durch. Also bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla. GitLab Actions haben sie jetzt am Start.
One of the biggest requests of all time has finally made it into GitLab. Okay.
Was wollen wir mal kurz machen? Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Mal ganz kurz, fünf Minuten.
Wir laden das runter und starten es. Was für Dinge. Ach, Act. Act ist GitLab Actions,
das kenne ich. Das ist GitLab Actions für lokal. Ja, das ist eine gute Wahl. Das ist sehr schlau
von denen, dass sie GitLab Actions geklont haben. Die haben GitLab Actions kopiert,
was sehr schlau ist, weil GitLab Actions finde ich das angenehmste System ist.
Okay, GCA Workflows. Okay. It is now possible to view ASCII Cast Files. Aha, auch cool.
Sie müssen halt nur aufpassen, dass es nicht komplett ausartet, dass GTA quasi so
neues GitLab wird mit bloated. Package Registries. Okay, die haben nicht nur eine
Container Registry, da kannst du dann quasi auch dein eigenes, deinen eigenen Cargo Server
mit hosten oder sowas. Was findest du an GitLab bloated? Naja, allein schon, dass du zwölf
Container brauchst oder so, wenn du starten willst. Du brauchst GitLab Server, du brauchst GitLab
Sidekick, du brauchst GitLab X, Y, Z, GitDies, GitDas. Also GitLab ist richtig fett, wenn du
es installieren willst. 85 Services, die da gestartet werden müssen. Brauche auch viel RAM
und Disk Space. Also GitLab selbst ist ziemlich fett. Ich meine, wenn du den
Hosted Service verwendest, also GitLab.com, dann ist es kein Ding.
Wir probieren das jetzt nicht aus. Mach ich in einem der nächsten Streams. Ich bin gerade zu
im Halbschlaf schon. Finde ich das eine coole Alternative. Kann man sich mal angucken. Machen
wir vielleicht sogar direkt im nächsten Stream. Finde ich eine coole Sache. So, also. Max,
weißt du, wie der Arbeitsmarkt für Beginner gerade ist? Das beste, beste Zeit, also in der
IT, meine ich jetzt. Es gab wohl keine bessere Zeit, in den Arbeitsmarkt einzusteigen, als jetzt.
Also Leute, IT Technik ist aktuell wirklich das Beste, was es gibt. Kann man nix sagen.
Also musst dir keine Sorgen machen. Hättest du gerade ein Tool, welches falsche Zeichen
aus Dateien rausnehmen kann, sind etwa 200 Gigabyte. 200 Gigabyte ist ordentlich. Crap wird dir nichts
bringen, weil es zahlenweise ist. Du könntest wahrscheinlich wirklich was mit Seht basteln,
wahrscheinlich, wenn es nur einzelne Zeichen sind. Ansonsten 200 Gigabyte ist schon ein bisschen was.
Also mir fällt jetzt kein Search and Place Tool ein, was super prädestiniert wäre,
dafür das zu machen. Also ich meine, mit einem Shellscript oder mit ein paar Sachen geht das
relativ einfach. Du könntest ein Find machen für alle Dateien und dann das in Seht öffnen und
das da durchjagen. Seht minus i für in place editieren. Also mit Seht kannst du ja quasi auch
die Datei direkt ändern. Das funktioniert, musst du ein bisschen aufpassen mit Eskapen,
beziehungsweise am besten den Seht-Ausdruck in Single Quotes machen. Da musst du dir um
das Eskapen keine Gedanken machen. Musst du dann aufpassen, dass du die Datei nicht einfach
kaputt machst. Kannst du natürlich auch ein Skript basteln dafür in einer anderen Sprache.
Aber mit Seht müsste das schon funktionieren.
Der AWK eher weniger in dem Fall. Ich würde es tatsächlich mal mit Seht probieren.
AWK ist nochmal eine Nummer mehr high IQ als Seht. Aber das sollte relativ easy sein. So
mal als Beispiel, nur so dass du mal auf die Schnelle gesehen hast. Also wahrgenommen du hast
jetzt hier Echo 1, 2, 3 und du willst jetzt da drinnen was replacen. Du willst die 1 löschen,
dann wird es so aussehen. Ich würde empfehlen, mach das immer in Single Quotes, sonst hast du
Probleme mit Eskapen. Also das hier ist der Ausdruck für Search und Replace. Zwischen
die ersten Slashes kommt das was du suchst, in die zweiten Slashes kommt das was du replacest.
So jetzt replacest du 1 durch 5. Es funktioniert auch an mehreren Stellen.
Musst du dir nur noch überlegen, wie du deine Files in Seht reinbekommst. Du siehst Seht macht
standardmäßig Standard Input, Standard Output. Aber du kannst auch Seht-i verwenden. Also machen
wir hier Echo 1, 2, 1, Blob.txt. Du kannst quasi, also hier guck, hier steht jetzt 1, 2, 1 in der
Datei. Du kannst aber auch sagen Seht-i in place edit und jetzt hast du die Datei editiert.
So sieht das Ganze aus. Wenn du jetzt eine größere Pile Struktur durchsehnen willst,
ich bin sicher ob das ein Recursive, nee hat es nicht, da musst du mit Find ran. Da müsstest du
dann quasi irgendwie Find machen und dann eine Schleife drüber und das dann irgendwie an Seht
übergeben. Vielleicht gehen auch X-Arcs, ich bin mir da gerade auf dem Kopf nicht sicher.
Das stimmt, ich habe es letztens wieder ausprobiert. Ich habe versucht das Ding
in ein Kombiniertes Cluster zu installieren. Für was steht Seht? Ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir nochmal. Seht, Linux, Wikipedia, jetzt wird ein Wikipedia Eintrag zu. Der Stream Editor,
alles klar. Die Possex-Brez. Ihh, wer macht denn sowas?
Wenn man was will, was aussieht wie 1995, obwohl ich nicht weiß,
sich mittlerweile besser aussieht. Genau, das war doch eigentlich ursprünglich sogar
ein Code Review Tool. Was will, was aussieht wie 1995, ist man da genau richtig.
Wirst du deinen jetzigen Arbeitgeber verraten, wenn du bei einem neuen anfängst? Also das kann
man jetzt ja auch falsch verstehen. Verraten heißt ja so viel wie hintergehen. Also ich werde den
weder hintergehen, noch werde ich verraten, wo ich gewesen bin. Ja, kann ich verstehen.
GitLab selber hosten ist wirklich Paynes Champ. Was ist eine Container Registry,
was macht man damit? Shifter, bist du noch da? Also, hast du mal Docker verwendet? Dort,
wo die ganzen Container Images gespeichert werden. Dort, wo die ganzen Docker Container
quasi gespeichert werden. Was ist eine Container Registry? Es ist nicht mal ganz korrekt,
wenn man sagt, Docker Container, genau genommen sind es ja OCI Container, aber jeder sagt Docker
Container und jeder weiß, was damit gemeint ist. Eigentlich sind es auch keine Container,
sondern Images. Eigentlich sind es OCI Images oder OCI Container Images oder wie auch immer,
aber es ist klar, was gemeint ist. Das macht man mit einer Container Registry.
Der Desktop ist ordentlich, seit ich auf Windows 11 bin. Ich habe hier einen neuen Rechner gekauft
und Windows 11 installiert und seitdem ist der Desktop halbwegs ordentlich. Aber nicht lange,
da wird schon wieder ein bisschen was dazukommen. Das sind doch die, die das gefolgt haben,
weil sie angeblich die guten sind. Bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander? Browser Tabs sind
leicht eskaliert. Naja, ich mache halt so selten den Kram zu. Wie viele Tage noch am
Arbeitsplatz? Die Woche und nächste Woche. Also quasi 5-6 Tage hier wahrscheinlich frei.
Was sagst du zum GPT? Dumerism. Oh, das ist ein geiles Wort, Alter. Dumerism können nur
Sumerisern machen. Richtig Dumer-Sumer. Also ich halte davon nichts. Ich glaube es ist nicht
wirklich gut abzuschätzen aktuell, was das alles genau heißen wird in der Zukunft. Ich denke eher,
dass es besser ist. Wäre übrigens es damals bei Dampfmaschinen und der Internet-Erfindung
auch gewesen. Wäre es damals bei Dampfmaschinen auch gewesen. Also ich denke es ist besser,
anstatt den Weltuntergang zu prophezeien, sich ein bisschen damit auseinanderzusetzen und zu
gucken, was man damit machen kann. Zu gucken, wie es einem selbst das Leben erleichtern kann.
Zu gucken, ob es einem selbst Arbeit abnehmen kann. Ob man vielleicht für sich selbst
irgendwelche Zukunft im AI-Bereich sieht. Ich meine, es hat keinen Sinn letzten Weltuntergang
herbeizureden oder das quasi zu ignorieren oder verbieten zu wollen oder abschaffen zu wollen.
Das wird eh nicht funktionieren, weil es ist egal, ob es dir persönlich nicht gefällt,
das wird eh kommen. Das wird eh gemacht werden. Wie man jetzt auch schon sieht. Nur weil jetzt
irgendwelche Leute denken, die Welt geht unter oder haben da keinen Bock drauf oder wollen das
nicht haben oder wollen das reglementiert haben oder wollen irgendwelche, habe ich ja schon
letztens in einer Talksendung gehört, einen Ethikrat für AI und sowas. Das können wir uns
auch nur in Deutschland ausdenken oder? Richtig per Pegashit. Wie kommt man auf solche Ideen,
man? Ein Ethikrat für AI. Was sollen die dann machen? Ist das eine super teuer bezahlte Position,
wo du dann irgendwelche Leute wieder abstellen kannst hin mit 150.000 Euro im Jahresgehalt plus
Bonus und weil es sonst irgendwo mal unterkriegst. Das einzige, was du machen kannst,
sind voll betrachtet, dass ich ein bisschen mit der Technik auseinandersetzen und sich überlegen,
was kann man selbst oder wie kann man da selbst so einen Vorteil draus ziehen?
Und ansonsten, es ist unglaublich schwierig abzuschätzen. Also ich denke,
was wir sagen können, ist, dass es auf viele Bereiche Einfluss haben wird. Dieses AI wird
das alles ersetzen. Das glaube ich nicht. Also gerade Chat-GPT faked sich ganz gerne was zusammen
und ich denke im Bereich der Softwareentwicklung, du kannst vielleicht in Zukunft so Fleißaufgaben
versuchen damit zu automatisieren. Zum Beispiel, ich habe eine .NET Anwendung,
die noch auf Framework 4.8 basiert. Schreibt mir das mal um in eine Anwendung, die auf .NET 7 läuft
oder sowas. Das könnte man vielleicht Chat-GPT machen lassen in Zukunft. Man muss dann halt
immer überprüfen, ob das auch wirklich das macht am Ende immer noch, was die Software machen soll,
weil das macht Chat-GPT halt gerne. Das fantasiert sich halt Zeugs zusammen und schreibt die halt so
hin, als wären es Fakten. Das merkt man wunderbar, wenn man zum Beispiel fragt nach irgendwelchen
Kommando-Zeilen-Tools und sich das ein bisschen genauer erklären lässt und sowas. Da kommen dann
ganz merkwürdige Sachen bei raus. Ist halt noch am Anfang. Ich meine, wenn man sich überlegt,
was sich da jetzt die letzten paar Jahre getan hat und sicherlich schon dabei sind, dass Chat-GPT
sich selbst verbessern kann, dann müssen wir gucken, was rauskommt. Also ich gehe davon aus,
dass es Auswirkungen auf sehr viele Bereiche haben wird. Es gibt viele Bullshit-Jobs,
die eigentlich keiner braucht. Ob die wirklich durch AI ersetzt werden? Tja,
ich weiß nicht. Ich denke schon, dass es in Zukunft deutlich weniger Jobs geben wird. Also,
es werden manche Berufsgruppen komplett wegfallen. Es wird in Zukunft keine Bergbauarbeiter
oder sowas mehr geben. Und es gibt auch weniger Leute, die am Fließband arbeiten. Es werden
schon einige Berufsgruppen wegfallen. Im gleichen Zuge wird es allerdings auch neue Jobs geben.
Allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht in diesem Maße, wie das dort wegfällt. Also mal angenommen,
du brauchst jetzt 100 Bergarbeiter nicht mehr. Du kannst jetzt nicht zu allen Bergarbeitern sagen,
mach eine Umschulung zum Fachinformatiker. Vielleicht jeden Zehnten. Und wenn ich mir
überlege, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Fließbandarbeiter ersetzt werden durch irgendwelche Roboter-Dinger,
AI nicht wirklich, irgendwelche Automatisierungs-Sachen, dann fallen da vielleicht 10 Stellen weg und es
werden zwei neue geschaffen für irgendwelche Techniker, die sich dann um den ganzen Automatisierungs-Gramm
kümmern müssen. Aber wie gesagt, das kann ich mir in Zukunft in so ziemlich allen Branchen außer
jetzt in der IT vorstellen, dass es dort ziemliche Ansammlungen geben wird an Leuten, die man dann
nicht mehr braucht. Das hat jetzt weniger mit AI zu tun, den Trend erkennt man in den letzten
Jahren schon. So und wie das mit dem Thema AI aussieht, ich denke im kreativen Bereich wird es
ganz viele AI-Retorten-Kunst und Texte und alles geben. Sieht man ja jetzt schon ein bisschen im
Ansatz. Es ist aktuell auf allen möglichen Diskussionsplattformen die Pest, also nicht nur
Bots, auch Leute, die in Stack Overflow keine Ahnung haben, aber Punkte sammeln wollen und dann
einfach Chat-GPT-Fragen und die Antwort reinpasten und sowas. Das ist mittlerweile nicht umsonst auf
vielen Diskussionsplattformen untersagt, Chat-GPT-Antworten zu posten. Weil das kann der
Fragesteller selbst machen und das sorgt einfach für unglaublich viel Rauschen in diesen
Diskussionsplattformen. Sei es jetzt Reddit, sei es irgendwelche Foren, sei es beispielsweise
die Home Assistant Community, die es letztens verboten hat, weil die Leute einfach hingegangen
sind, haben eine Frage von jemandem in Chat-GPT gepostet und dann in das Diskussionsforum die
Antwort drunter. Das ist natürlich komplett unsinnig. Also es wird auf jeden Fall sehr viele
so Retorten, AI, Texte und Bilder und sowas in Zukunft geben, aber ich glaube, dass es noch
eine ganze Weile hin ist. Ich sage nicht, dass das nicht passieren wird, aber ich glaube,
ich glaube, es ist noch eine ganze Weile hin, dass man von einer AI, was wirklich,
wie soll man das nennen? Neues ist das ja schon, was wirklich originelles vielleicht,
könnte man vielleicht, könnte man das so nennen, was wirklich künstlerisch quasi originelles mit
tieferem Sinn sieht. Also das glaube ich, das wird noch eine Weile dauern. Es wird aber auf
jeden Fall auch viele Bereiche Einfluss haben. Also da bin ich mir sicher. Irgendwie einen
Weltuntergang prophezeien würde ich nicht. Es hat eh keinen Sinn. Selbst, selbst wenn man
da total dagegen ist. Es wird weitergehen mit der Entwicklung und wahrscheinlich sind wir dann in
Deutschland wieder so damit beschäftigt, darüber zu diskutieren und das zu reglementieren und ein
Ethikrat zu gründen und irgendwie kommt dann die neue Chat-GPT-EU-App, die keiner verwendet und wir
werden da wieder irgendwie total, total Blödsinn wieder veranstalten, sodass wir wahrscheinlich in
zehn Jahren wieder komplett abgehängt sind, was das Thema AI anbelangt. Also an so den IT-Standort
Deutschland, da habe ich ja echt, auch was so die Rahmenbedingungen und sowas angeht, da erwarte
ich wenig Innovation in der Richtung. Wahrscheinlich werden wir es da so verkacken wie mit dem Internet-Ausbau
und in zehn Jahren werden wir uns fragen, guck mal da, in, keine Ahnung, in Afrika laufen die
Plantagen jetzt automatisch mit AI-generierter Bewässerungsanlage und wir diskutieren auch im
AI-Ethikrat, ob man das machen sollte oder nicht. Naja, es wird eh passieren. Gib uns mal einen
Crashkurs in GitHub Actions. Könnte man tatsächlich mal machen. Gute Idee. Hast du die Apokalypse
mitbekommen? Man kann Bilder, die mit einem Pixelform geschnitten sind,
teilweise komplett wiederherstellen. Du meinst, die verpixelt wurden, die Bilder oder wie? Weil,
wenn das einfach schwarzes Rechteck auf dem Bild ist, dann kannst du das ja nicht wieder herstellen.
Hä, wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie soll das funktionieren, wenn das Bild weg ist, ist es weg?
Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Okay, ich habe als erste, erste, was ich dazu gefunden habe.
Google Pixel exploit reverse editing parts of screenshots. Hä? Das heißt,
die behalten den original Screenshot oder wie und editieren dann daraus ein neues Bild oder?
Achso.
Also, irgendjemand hat mit diesem Google Markup Tool, also okay, jemand mal mit dem
Google Markup Tool seine Kredit, aber wie soll das gehen? Ich meine, wenn die Datei
doch wirklich gespeichert ist mit schwarzem Text drüber, haben die in dem PNG noch irgend,
wie soll das funktionieren? Original wird weiter gespeichert. Ja gut, das Original ist doch egal,
wenn es ein Discord Message ist oder ist das Original weiterhin in dem Bild mit drinnen,
dass es quasi ein Bild ist mit einem Markup Overlay, also dass es quasi ein Layer ist und
nicht eine neu, wie soll man sagen, neu gebackene Bilddatei mit dem Overlay drinnen.
Aha, weil wenn ich das Bild jetzt screenshotte und speichere,
dann ist da nichts mehr mit Recoveren. Ah, okay, die haben das Neue am Anfang geschrieben und die
Daten quasi hinten dran hängen lassen. Okay, das ist natürlich ziemlich fail. Google,
gut, dass ich das nicht verwende. Das geht aber auch dann nur, das geht nur, wenn das Bild nicht
weiter verarbeitet wurde. Also in Discord kann ich das hochladen, weil Discord verarbeitet das
Bild ja nicht weiter, sondern Discord hostet quasi das Original PNG. Wenn man das auf Twitter
hochlädt, wird aus seinem abgelaudeten PNG ein neues PNG gemacht. Ich glaube,
auf Twitter würde das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Also Twitter reencoded,
das glaube ich. Zumindest, okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Twitter das reencoded. Twitter
löscht halt ein paar Sachen aus dem PNG, zum Beispiel Exif-Informationen von wo das Bild kommt und so
was. Also sobald es reencoded wird, ist das wahrscheinlich clean. Ja, sister Twitter
reprocessed das. Ja, okay, interessant. Also wenn man auf Discord seine Sachen gepostet hat,
hat man ziemlich die Arschkarte. Ja, Discord macht das nicht. Discord stellt das einfach nur da.
Interessant, ne, habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Da bin ich ja wirklich froh, dass ich keinen Google
Pixel habe. Wie findest du J-Flock-Artifact? Es klingt nach Java. Da halte ich Abstand von.
Ja, wir schauen uns im nächsten Stream an. Wisst ihr, was ich heute gemacht habe? Ich habe
heute ein bisschen mit Google Cloud rumgespielt. Ich habe einen Google Cloud Autopilot Kubernetes
Cluster angelegt, per Jaml einen Ingress mit Zertifikat und eine Managed Postgres Datenbank.
Und ich muss sagen, das war erstaunlich einfach. Also ich habe schneller durchgeblickt als den
Azure. Gut, von AWS fange ich gar nicht mal an. Bei AWS heißt das Zeug ja random, einfach nur.
Also AWS Services müssen immer so benannt sein, dass du vom Namen keine Rückschlüsse
drauf ziehen kannst, was es eigentlich ist. Also AWS wäre zum Beispiel, stellt euch mal vor,
AWS würde Managed Prometheus anbieten oder so. Oder Managed Gitea anbieten. Dann würde das nicht
bei AWS heißen. AWS Source Code, sondern es würde heißen Elastic Seamonster oder so was. Und dann
denkst du dir, was zum Teufel ist Elastic Seamonster? Und dann würde dir dann der Amazon Vertreter
sagen, na klar, das ist unsere Git Hosting Plattform. Das Zeug heißt gerne Elastic und
dann random hinten dran. Elastic, dann hast du Fargate und solche Geschichten, wo man sich so denkt,
was ist da bei AWS immer los? Warum benennen die das Zeug so komisch, dass man es nicht versteht?
Irgendwie mal Shithub Enterprise gehostet? Nein. Hab ich nie. Ist wahrscheinlich auch
Pain in the Ass, das zu hosten. Ich mein GitLab ist schon Plotted as Fuck zum selben Hosten,
da will ich gar nicht wissen, wie Plotted as Fuck GitHub erst sein muss zum selben Hosten.
Was mich ja persönlich interessieren würde ist, ob GitHub immer noch auf Ruby on Rails
Basis ist. Ich kann es mir schwerlich vorstellen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass Teile noch in Ruby on Rails sind, so die sich irgendwie seit zehn Jahren nicht geändert haben.
Aber ich denke mal, dass die interne Architektur von GitHub mittlerweile sehr modular ist. So
Microservice mäßig asynchron Daten verarbeitet werden mit Message Cues dazwischen und ich glaube
davon ist relativ wenig noch in Ruby on Rails. Rate ich jetzt mal, also würde ich erwarten. Ich
habe keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist. Also früher war GitHub komplett Ruby on Rails,
GitLab übrigens auch. Mittlerweile kann ich mir bei GitHub nicht mehr vorstellen,
dass das noch viel Ruby on Rails drinne ist. Was ist deine Meinung zu dem Thema LLMs? Was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Language Models oder was? Ach, du meinst sowas? Ach,
jetzt weiß ich, jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst. Ich sollte es mal vielleicht komplett. Na gut,
da habe ich ja gerade schon was dazu gesagt. Das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich nicht. Wie
gesagt, Programmieren ist eine kreative Tätigkeit und Fleißarbeiten bzw. kontrollieren lassen
bzw. auch die AI-Fragen so nach dem Motto Hey, was macht diese Methode oder schreibt mir dreizeilige
Hilfetexts für die Funktion und sowas. Dafür kann ich mir das durchaus vorstellen. Ich gehe
davon aus, dass es in vielen Bereichen Einzug halten wird als Unterstützung. Aber du brauchst
immer noch jemand, zumindest zum aktuellen Stand und zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, jemand,
der das Ganze kontrolliert und der das auf Plausibilität checkt, was da rauskommt.
Max, hast du ein Steam Deck? Meine Meinung dazu? Habt ihr mir jetzt im
Seil? Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich habe aber was Besseres für mich gefunden,
weil ich will ja nicht unterwegs spielen. Mit einem Steam Deck will ich nicht unterwegs
spielen. Ich habe mir eine Emulator-Kiste gebaut letztens. Dieses Teil hier, wo sieht man es denn
da? Ja, das Ding. Das ist nice. Da kannst du sogar Re-Spiele upscaled auf 4K spielen. Extrem
Pog. Placingly fast written in Rust. Natürlich. Natürlich. Warum sollte es für Seed nicht auch
eine Rust-Implementierung geben? Aber Projekt ist dead. Das ist halt das Problem bei diesen ganzen
Re-Rides. Da sind dann immer Single-Maintainer-Dinger, wo der nach ein paar Jahren keinen Bock mehr hat.
Die Post-Express. Wie gesagt, ich werde nicht erzählen, wo ich aktuell arbeite oder wo ich
gearbeitet werden habe. In zwei Wochen werde ich euch nicht erzählen. Moin, schreibe seit ein paar
Tagen mal bei einem großen Konzern meine Masterarbeit. Exzellent. Da bist du genau
richtig. Hier sind noch mehr High-IQ-Leute im Chat. Im Data-Science-Forschungsbereich und ich bin
schwer davon ausgegangen, dass alles perfekt laufen würde in solchen großen Unternehmen. Nee,
auf gar keinen Fall. Warum hat er eine Flasche auf dem Kopf stehen? Weit gefehlt. Umso größer die
Unternehmen sind, umso mehr Blödsinn läuft da wahrscheinlich und umso bürokratischer ist es.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt noch nie bei riesengroßen Unternehmen gearbeitet.
Also so mit 50.000 plus oder so. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich habe bei großen Unternehmen gearbeitet,
also 1.000 plus, 2.000, 3.000 plus und da wird so viel Blödsinn gemacht und die linke Hand weiß
nicht, was die andere machen. Das ist das Gegenteil von perfekt laufen. Vor allem hast du umso größer,
das ist immer mehr Kleinkriege so zwischen dem einen Teamleiter und dem anderen Teamleiter und
der Abteilungstyp will eher das Budget für seine Abteilung und nicht der anderen Abteilung. Also
Großunternehmen werfen sich gerne selbst immer so Stöcke in den Weg, also Stöcke zwischen die
Beine. Das liegt auch daran, dass du bei so großen Unternehmen so viele Leute
hast. Die können ja gar nicht alle gut in ihrem Job sein. Guck mal, wenn du im Unternehmen bist
mit mit keine Ahnung 50.000 plus Mitarbeitern oder so, können doch gar nicht alle gut in ihrem
Job sein. Da hast du ganz großen Teil Unfähige auch am Start, mit denen du dich dann rumschlagen
musst. Es lässt sich ja nicht vermeiden. Wie viele Tage noch am alten Arbeitsplatz? Ja,
noch zwei Wochen. Ist dein Desktop vielleicht voll? Das Problem hatte ich auch schon. Ist
dein Desktop voller Icons? Also nicht so wie meiner, sondern wie mein alter. Also ist der
auch komplett voll mit Icons, dein Desktop? Lösch die mal bzw. verschiebt die meinen Ordner. Ich
hatte auch das Problem, dass mein Explorer bzw. auch das File Browsing Window übertrieben langsam
war, als mein Desktop so voll war. Komplett leer? Dann weiß ich auch nicht. Ich glaube teilweise
schon ein bisschen. Vielleicht kann ich ja in Zukunft den ein oder anderen noch nachholen,
wenn es da jetzt komplett den Bach runtergehen sollte. Kannst du uns mal deine Skillliste in den
Chat schicken? Nee, aber ich kann sie noch mal zeigen. Dann kannst du dir sie in Ruhe durchlesen.
Im Wort. Macht nicht alles Sinn, was ich reingeschrieben habe.
Ja, solche Sachen wird es geben in Zukunft. Keine Frage. Bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass es
Jobs geben wird, die quasi AI Output grob überfliegen. Es gibt ja jetzt auch quasi am
Fließband gibt es doch jetzt auch Leute, die noch mal Endkontrolle machen, so nach dem Motto
hier ist ein bisschen was Schäpp aussortiert, hier ist was oben abgebrochen aussortiert. Ich
gehe stark davon aus, dass es solche Jobs auch geben wird für AI Output. In Stellen, wo man
feststellt, also in Aufgaben, wo man in Zukunft feststellen wird, dass ich AI, also ich kann jetzt
kein konkretes Beispiel sagen, also man wird in Zukunft sicherlich feststellen, dass ich für
manche Aufgaben, die AI zum aktuellen Entwicklungsstand gut dafür eignet, eine zufriedenstellende
Qualität, also Output in zufriedenstellender Qualität zu liefern. Sagen wir mal das,
dass es zu 90 Prozent eigentlich passt und an diesen Stellen wird es dann oder vielleicht
dann auch mit bisschen Training und Weiterentwicklung 95 Prozent, dass der Output gut ist und gut passt
und dann wird es garantiert Leute geben, die den Output auch noch mal nicht alles hundertprozentig
durchlesen, sondern so quer lesen und checken. Also je nachdem, lesen ist jetzt in Anführungsstrichen
zu setzen, weil es muss nicht zwangsläufig den Output lesen, es wird nicht zwangsläufig Texte
generiert wird. Also das, was die AI quasi ausspuckt bzw. machen will, dass das noch mal
auf Plausibilität und irgendwelche Lücken und Probleme noch mal kurz durchgeguckt wird,
sodass du dann quasi auch so die fünf Prozent Fehler eine Chance hast, das zu merken. Also ich
gehe davon aus, sowas wird es in Zukunft geben. Wann kommt deine neue Folge, was musst du für deine,
das ist eine gute Frage. Die Sachen kamen nicht so gut an, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da noch was
zu erzählen soll, keine Ahnung. Ich habe zwei Videos gemacht, ich fand die gut. Ich fand auch,
dass das wichtig ist. Ich glaube, in dem einen habe ich erzählt, dass man gut googeln können
muss. Also die kamen aber nicht so gut an, die Videos. Also wahrscheinlich werde ich da keins
machen. Zurzeit für IT-Mythen. AI-Edition. Leute, wollen wir mal Chat-GPT fragen? Ich muss mal
kurz gucken, ob ich noch eingeloggt bin. Nice, ich bin noch eingeloggt. Okay, gut. Okay, ich bin
noch eingeloggt, dann können wir uns, das kann ich wieder anmachen. Oh nee. Hi. Ah nee, geht doch,
geht doch. Nenne mir zehn IT-Mythen. Wie könnte man das noch schreiben? Nenne mir zehn Unbekannte.
Im Edge ist schon GPT-4 am Start. Hier sind unbekannte, häufige IT-Mythen. Max sind völlig
immun gegen Viren und andere Malware. Ein privates Surfen im Kognit, das habe ich sogar selbst schon
mal in einem Video erwähnt. Ein höherer Megapixel wird bei einer Kamera bedeuten,
die Deinstallation von nicht. Internet Explorer ist das sicherste Browser, weil er von Microsoft
kommt. Gibt es wirklich jemand, der das erzählt? Dann machen wir jetzt, wie kann man Chat-GPT
als fragen, ob man das magst du C++? Okay. Nenne mir zehn IT-Mythen, die nicht jeder kennt.
Hier sind zehn weniger bekannte IT-Mythen. Das Ausschalten. Moment, was? Das Ausschalten des
PCs kann das BIOS beschädigen. Niemand hat das jemals irgendwo behauptet. Habt ihr das schon mal
irgendwo im Ansatz gehört? Die Verwendung von WLAN kann Risiko zur Kopfschmerzen im Gehirn,
Gehirnkrebs erhöhen. Das ist wohl wahr. Das ist tatsächlich ein verbreiteter Irrglaube und 5G
erst. Was hat 5G mit Bill Gates zu tun und ist 5G schädlich? Es gibt eine Verschwörungstheorie,
alles klar. Okay, wir lesen uns gleich durch. Ja, ich habe jetzt auch 5G auf dem Handy. So was
hatten wir. Wenn sie ihre Daten von einer SSD löschen, sind sie unwiederbringlich verloren.
Naja, so sehr mythen ist das gar nicht. Also es ist ungleich schwerer, natürlich kommt das auf
das Filesystem ein bisschen an, aber es ist ungleich schwerer von einer SSD Sachen zu
recovern als von einer Magnetfallsplatte. Wenn sie einen USB-Stick an einen anderen
USB-Port anschließen können, das hat nie jemand behauptet. Die Verwendung von Kaffee
als Flüssigkeit zum Kühlen von Computern kann die Leistung verwenden. Niemand. JET-GPT fantasiert
sich wieder irgendwelche Sachen zusammen. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Okay,
es gibt eine Verschwörungstheorie, die behauptet, dass Bill Gates und 5G zusammenhängen. Diese
Theorie behauptet, okay. Okay. Kennst du Obamas Echsenmensch-Bodyguard? Das Allermichtigste.
Alles klar, JET-GPT erklärt es uns. Es gibt keine Beweise für die Existenz von Echsenmännchen.
Ich dachte, das ist allgemein anerkannte Fakt. Warum sagt JET-GPT, JET-GPT muss ich einfach mal
unabhängig informieren im Internet, dann wüsste es auch, dass es Echsenmenschen gibt.
JET-GPT, kein Plan von der Realität. Man, Echsenmenschen gibt es nicht, was sie uns
erzählen wollen. Beweise mir, dass es keine Echsenmenschen gibt. Reptilien, alles klar.
Es ist unglaublich schwierig, das Gegenteil zu beweisen. Es gibt natürlich gerade mathematische
Sachen, kann man teilweise das Gegenteil beweisen, so nach dem Motto, gibt es nur eine endliche
Anzahl von Primzahlen und das kann man dann widerlegen, indem man sagt, man kann quasi
neue konstruieren und deswegen gibt es unendlich viele und die Annahme ist falsch. Insgesamt
ist es schwierig, Sachen zu negativ beweisen. Es ist unglaublich viel schwieriger, das Gegenteil
zu beweisen, von einer Behauptung als für denjenigen, der die Behauptung aufgestellt hat.
Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde, Leute, wusstet ihr, dass ein Stück Kacke von mir um die
Erde kreist im Weltall, dann würdet ihr sagen, Max, das ist aber ganz schön weit hergeholt jetzt,
aber könntet ihr mir wirklich das Gegenteil beweisen, dass kein Stück Kacke von mir um die
Erde kreist, ist ganz schön schwierig, das Gegenteil zu beweisen, oder? Die Behauptung
aufstellen kann ich relativ easy. Das Gegenteil beweisen könnt ihr im Endeffekt fast gar nicht.
Wie wollt ihr das machen? Und selbst wenn ihr ins Weltall fliegt und nachguckt und ein Stück
Scheiße findet und analysiert biologisch und feststellt, das ist nicht von mir, dann kann ich
immer noch sagen, ihr habt einfach nicht am richtigen Ort geguckt. Also das Gegenteil zu
beweisen ist oftmals gar nicht möglich. Deswegen ist es ja auch normalerweise so,
dass derjenige, der was behauptet, das beweisen muss oder das beweisen sollte,
dass man ihm Glauben schenkt. Das ist oftmals, was bei so ganzen Verschwörungstheorien immer
so ein bisschen rumgedreht wird. Wir behaupten das jetzt einfach mal und du kannst auch nicht
beweisen, dass es nicht stimmt. Das ist aber halt der bescheuerte Ansatz, weil wenn wirklich
irgendjemand behauptet, Obama ist ein Echsenmensch oder Obama hat ein Echsenmensch-Bodyguard,
dann ist das erstmal so eine wirre Annahme, dass er jetzt zumindest mal ein bisschen in
Vorleistung treten müsste und so einen Beweisansatz bringen müsste, warum das so ist. Ansonsten kann
er einfach sagen, ja ich weiß, dass das so ist, beweise mir doch, dass es nicht so ist. Ja das
kannst du ja nicht. Wie willst du das machen? Es gibt einige, die haben mit Chetki-PT schon
Bewerbungen automatisiert und bewerben sich mit Individuen. Also das ist das, was ich vorhin meine.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ganz viel so AI-Retortentexte und Bilder in Zukunft geben
wird, die auch teilweise schon richtig nervig sein werden. Wie gesagt, in Diskussionsforen,
auch auf Reddit, in der Homosystem-Community, überall ist es die Pest, überall wird Chetki-PT-Antworten
gepostet. Das konnte der Fragesteller doch selbst. Das ist wirklich ein Bereich, wo ich sage,
okay, dann verstehe ich, wenn man sagt, AI-Antworten unerwünscht. Was nicht dagegen
spricht, dass man nicht eine gute Antwort postet, in die vielleicht Sachen eingeflossen sind,
die man von der AI hat, oder man die Antwort weiß, kein Bock hat, den Text selbst zu schreiben,
ist der AI erklärt und sie schreibt einem einen Text, sowas. Das ist ja dann okay. Aber so dieses,
ich paste die Frage aus dem Diskussionsforum in Chetki-PT und paste dann die Antwort dann
wieder dazu rein, ist einfach nur sinnlos Spam zum größten Teil.
Ja, habe ich schon gesagt, ich habe da keine Verwendung für, aber meine Emulator-Kiste benutze
ich trotzdem gerne. Würdest du sagen, dass Chetki-PT eine starke AI ist? Ja, würde ich. Das
ist die beste AI, die wir bisher zustande bekommen haben. Hat sich dein Lebensstil
durch höheres Gehalt geändert? Nö. Das ist ja das Ding. Ich gebe so gut wie kein Geld aus.
Ich fahre nicht groß in Urlaub. Ich kaufe mir alle fünf Jahre teuren Rechner. Ich mache keine
großen teuren Kreuzfahrten oder Ausflüge oder kaufe mir teure Klamotten oder teure Autos oder
sowas. Ich gebe kaum Geld aus. Ich habe noch nie viel Geld ausgegeben.
Ich glaube, das ist eher so eine Persönlichkeitsfrage. Es gibt Leute, die haben ein gutes Gefühl oder so.
Das erfüllt die, wenn sie sich was teures gekauft haben und manche geben damit an,
manchen reicht es auch einfach, es zu besitzen, es zu haben, sich anzugucken. Es gibt Leute,
die stehen da drauf, sich Autos zu kaufen oder irgendwie mit einem Maßanzug rumzulaufen. Ich
dachte da gar nichts gegen. Das kann ja wirklich jeder machen, wie er will. Aber es gibt Leute,
denen gibt das was. Oder früher, als iPhones neu waren, mit dem iPhone in der Bahn zu posieren und
sowas. Es gibt Leute, die stehen so auf so materielle Dinger. Mir gibt das wenig. Ich freue mich über
andere Sachen. Ich freue mich zum Beispiel, wenn ich an irgendwas gebastelt habe und nach drei
Wochen geht es endlich. Das ist zum Beispiel was, da kann ich mich drüber freuen. Ich habe
irgendwas programmiert und es funktioniert genauso wie gedacht. Ich gucke mir irgendwelche
neuen Technikgeschichten an und kann sie dann benutzen. Es funktioniert so, wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe. Also, so materielle Sachen sind mir eigentlich ziemlich wurscht. Das heißt nicht,
dass ich gar kein Geld ausgebe. Ich habe mir letztens ein Auto gekauft, weil das alte nur
wirklich schon ziemlich im Arsch war. Ich gebe schon ab und zu Geld aus. Ich habe mir zu Weihnachten
im Dezember einen neuen Rechner gekauft, aber ich habe mir auch seit fünf Jahren erst mal
wieder einen neuen Rechner gekauft. Was sind noch so deine Ziele im Leben? Soll ich dir das mal ganz
ehrlich sagen? Soll ich euch sagen, was meine Ziele sind? Meine Ziele sind möglichst alt zu
werden in einem möglichst guten Zustand und in dieser Zeit möglichst viel das machen zu können,
worauf ich Bock habe. Das kann sich ändern, worauf ich Bock habe. Aber das ist mein Ziel.
Ich möchte nicht mein Leben mit Arbeit unbedingt verbringen die ganze Zeit oder mit irgendwelchen
nervigen Sachen. Das sind Dinge, dafür gebe ich zum Beispiel Geld aus. Also, wenn ich die Auswahl
habe zwischen gehst du jetzt noch mal raus ins Geschäft und kaufst das oder bestellst es bei
Amazon, dann bestelle ich es bei Amazon, auch wenn es fünf Euro teurer ist. Einfach weil ich keinen
Bock habe mich zu bewegen und Zeit darauf zu verschwenden. Oder ich würde mir auch wenn es
wenn das zur aktuellen Lebenssituation passt, würde ich mir auch ein HelloFreshAbo oder sowas
holen, dass ich mal einkaufen gehen müsste oder Rewe mit Liefer-Service bestellen, was auch immer.
Alles was mir Arbeit abnimmt, die ich nicht gerne mache, dafür gebe ich auch mal ein bisschen Geld
aus. Aber ansonsten, ich möchte möglichst alt werden, in einem Zustand, dass ich was von habe
und in der Zeit so viel wie möglich machen, worauf ich Bock habe. Worauf ich Bock habe kann
übrigens auch sein, ich meine damit jetzt gar nicht super hochgesteckte Ziele, worauf ich Bock
habe kann auch sein, dass ich einfach mal einen kompletten Tag mich hinsetze und MMO-Kreisel-Crime
mache. Das zählt für mich auch dabei, wenn ich Bock habe. Und das Gute ist, was wirklich nice ist,
wo ich mir zumindest denke, ich werde jetzt 39, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr extrem jung,
aber auch noch nicht steinalt. Ich werde bald 39 in ein paar Monaten. Ich denke da habe ich es echt
ganz gut mit 39, also schon mit 39 schon. Ich habe genug Kohle, dass ich im Prinzip alles machen kann,
was ich will. Ich arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche, das heißt ich habe relativ viel Zeit auch das zu
machen, was ich will. Das in Kombination mit genug Geld ist natürlich auch nice. Ich habe ein Haus,
ich kann eigentlich, ich habe einen YouTube-Channel, ich mache Twitch-Stalls, habe da
noch ein bisschen nebenbei Einnahmen, wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, dass ich weder YouTube noch
Twitch, auch wenn ich natürlich gerne eure Prime-Subs nehme, aber ich muss sagen, dass ich
weder YouTube noch Twitch mache, weil ich irgendwie mir da die große Kohle von verspreche. Wenn ich mir
davon die große Kohle versprechen würde, dann würde ich das anders machen. Also wenn ich die große
Kohle habe, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr Collaborations machen, würde ich auch Leute
anschreiben, so nach dem Motto hast du nicht mal Bock, wollen wir nicht mal. Es ist ja aktuell eher
so, dass ich sage, nach nee, lass mal, kein Bock. Immer Collaborations, viel mehr Videos, viel mehr
aktuelle Trends, aber habe ich überhaupt keinen, habe ich überhaupt keinen Nerv drauf. Das ist
auch sehr beruhigend, dass ich mir immer sagen kann, sollte mir was auf der Arbeit auf den Sack
gehen. Ich müsste es nicht machen, ich habe erstens genug Geld und zweitens immer ein Dach
über dem Kopf und drittens noch einen zweiten Job, was Twitch und YouTube angeht, wo ich mehr
machen könnte und auch so nicht morgen unter der Brücke schlafen müsste und umgedreht, wenn mir
Twitch oder YouTube auf den Sack geht, denke ich mir, na gut, ich muss es nicht machen, es reicht ja
auch so. Ja, also nee, mein Lebensstil hat sich nicht wirklich geändert, doch ich habe jetzt keinen
Opel Agila mehr, ich habe jetzt einen Fiat 500e, kein Agila Lifestyle mehr. Also nee, hat sich nicht,
man kann das selbst natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht beurteilen, aber ich würde sagen,
hat sich nicht. OnlyFans, nee, nee, nee, wenn schon nur Fansli, nur Fansli.
Null. Vor allen Dingen fängst du unfähige Leute in großen Unternehmen meistens auf, das stimmt,
das stimmt. Wenn ich mal bei uns rumgucke, es gibt da schon einige Leute, wo ich mich frage,
was ist eigentlich die Daseinsberechtigung. Lustiges Meme gerade gesehen, ich traue mich
nicht drauf zu klicken im Stream. Ich mache das jetzt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht, Zufallsgenerator, Merth Random, Wagenreihungs-Api. Das ist schon
das, das ist ein Jubel. Mein Lieblings Random-Meme ist immer noch das von Debian. Dieses Debian
Random-Generator-Meme mit diesem Return 5 oder Return 4. Def Random Return 5. Da war doch vor
paar Jahren mal, falls ich da noch jemand dran erinnern kann, gab es noch ein Bug unter Debian
im Random-Generator, dass SSH-Keys irgendwie nur noch 60.000 verschiedene generiert wurden
oder sowas. War ziemlich fail. Ist der Laptop schwerer, wenn die Festplatte voll ist? Das ist
eine gute Frage. Fangen wir doch mal. Nein, die Festplattenkapazität eines Laptops oder es
geht um das Gewicht hat keinen Einfluss auf das Gewicht des Geräts. Also die Festplattenkapazität
selbst hat schon Einfluss potentiell auf das Gewicht, weil da sind mehr Scheiben drin. Also
so ganz korrekt ist die Antwort nicht. Aber die Festplatte ist natürlich nicht schwerer,
wenn sie voll ist. Aber das ist eine gute Frage, um AIs zu testen.
Wie gesagt, mein neuer Handy-Vertrag hat auch 5G. O2 hat es jetzt endlich hinbekommen. Stellt euch
das mal vor, Leute. Richtiges PP-Gas bei O2. Aber sie haben es geschafft. Hat nur lange gedauert.
Hat fast viereinhalb Tage gedauert.
Ich habe auch schon mal eine Ölkühlung von Rechnern gesehen, schon bevor es das mal beim
Bauer gab. Das ist halt auch so was Unsinniges.
Ja, für JetGPT 4 musst du 20 Euro oder 20 Dollar im Monat bezahlen.
Was kannst du derzeit an Games empfehlen? Das Dead Space Remake. Das ist wirklich nice.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand das Original trotzdem besser. Einfach weil es das Original ist und
damals was ganz Neues war. Aber es ist ein gutes Remake. Kann man es echt mal wieder geben. Vor
allem wenn ihr noch nie Dead Space gespielt habt, kann ich das Dead Space Remake wirklich zu 90
Prozent empfehlen, wenn euch Third Party Shooter und ein bisschen Horror-Einschlag gefällt. Das
Dead Space Remake ist wirklich gut. Nö, ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock. Ich habe überhaupt keinen
Bock irgendwie groß hinzufahren. Ja, okay, dann müsste ich wahrscheinlich irgendwo hinfahren.
Stimmt eigentlich. Es gibt ja nur 50.000 Menschen auf der Welt,
reichen 60.000 SSH Keys auch locker. Kann mir jemand vielleicht erklären,
wie ich den Fehler 4000, den was? Was ist der Fehler 4000? In Twitch. Also in Chromium kann sein,
dass du Codec-Probleme hast, je nachdem was für ein Chromium-Build du dir runtergeladen hast.
Es gibt ja Chromium-Builds ohne Media-Codecs und dann geht das Stream nicht. Was war denn
eigentlich bei O2? Ich weiß es nicht. Das werden die mir auch nicht sagen.
Also wenn du ganz furchtbar schnell bist und der Rechner gerade nicht viel verbraucht,
kann ich mir das durchaus vorstellen, wenn du schnell bist. Wenn du schnell bist und der
Rechner gerade irgendwie bei 8 Watt oder so rum eidet, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das möglich
ist. Wenn du wirklich schnell bist. Probier es mal lieber mit einem Schalter. Den Schalter
dann quasi ganz schnell. Das könnte vielleicht gehen, aber es ist eher unwahrscheinlich,
aber es könnte schon sein. Also wo es auf jeden Fall geht ist, wenn es nicht der PC ist,
an einem Microcontroller. Also wenn man zum Beispiel einen ESP32 hat und den an so einem
fetten Klotz hängen hat an der Steckdose, dann kannst du ohne Probleme das Ding quasi aus der
Steckdose ziehen und der ESP läuft irgendwie noch 10 Sekunden weiter.
Mr. Amek, danke schon für den Sub. Nice. Leute, ich bin ja pünktlich um 22 Uhr fertig mit Chat
lesen. Nächsten Stream probiere ich mal Schetea aus, würde ich sagen. Bin gespannt,
wie das mit Container Registry und GitHub Actions aussieht. Leute, wollen wir mal wieder
gute Nachtmusik machen? Moment, das ist nicht das Original.
Ist das Seriously? Keine? Das ist nicht das Original.
Warum gibt es den Soundtrack von einem 14-Moment, von einem 17 Jahre altem Spiel nicht mehr?
Ja, das hier. Ja, die haben eine eingebaute Registry. Wann nächster Stream? Die Tage. Ich
kann es dir noch nicht genau sagen. Würde sagen, jetzt ist Bedgetime. Ja, dann schlafen wir
gut, Leute. Falls ihr jetzt auch pennen geht. Geht ihr jetzt pennen? Immerhin 22 Uhr. Manche
werden jetzt erst richtig wach. Na gut, bis denn, Leute. Macht's gut. See you.